[Music]
we started to get into this in the last
segment people started to pile on - you
know what start ones try and have this
be everyone has to get their say for
example I'm told that one of you I
believe Simon does a killer Kunal
impression what's it based on and how
does it work
oh well it's based on this buffoon
sitting next to ya I'm tried out for the
band but his hat wasn't small enough oh
no he will he just you know he he talks
a lot about food a lot very seriously
and he's very passionate he comes in
here oh my god boot so last night look
you've got to go to this place downtown
it's a it's so young I got this branzino
and like this they take this olive and
they just like set it on fire and
explode
[Laughter]
on the island of Jamaica when you talk
about food but also I've heard that
there's and this is something you all
agree on apparently that you that you
all feel that Kunal is often wrong Oh is
the most consistently incorrect man I've
ever met
what is the most consistent thank you so
if all I ask
Kunal when is our run through this
afternoon two or three if he says three
I know it's too late we're meeting
somewhere and I called Kaylee I said
where is this restaurant she goes you
know where it is I said I don't I've
never heard of it before [ __ ] out what I
saw was your favorite restaurant the
trick is to see anything with conviction
thank you you just said but you also say
the wrong thing at the wrong time
my am I'm told you guys were at an
awards show and you would just law tell
us what happened it was some awards show
we're like it was like Jim lost I lost
the show lost within like five minutes
and couldn't always like but we're all
together we loved each other and we were
all like it's too soon right now or feel
good I didn't remember that he used to
always predict our eventual win it all
but we are going to win this year never
even say that you know it don't worry
about a speech he came in again I think
it was like 20 minutes later he's like
how about now guys always ready to toast
yeah yeah you also you love listening to
Kunal get his makeup on is that right
Melissa I love listening to the two of
them in the makeup room their their
banter together is just so fantastic it
Simon usually making fun of him and
Kunal coming back it's like the best
rom-com ever but now that I don't mean
that not that they're in love or
anything no but in time that could
develop is it true you guys all have a
problem with how Kunal parks his car
yeah Haley do you want to take the lead
on that
this it's gotten better it's gotten
better
he is depart we cool it that's why I got
better yeah so he we're all near each
other in the spaces I'll give it to her
not that big he'd take it like a scar
and pull it so far and so though his
whole backside of it is out and I have
to park next to him and every time I
pull it I'm just be like in my pens I
have a car whose doors open like that's
not how you get people there are only
three of them in the world and when my
car takes off have a photograph someone
all of you took the photograph he's
halfway on the mark leaving lots of room
on one side not as much on the other and
that's giving him an extra wide space
yeah wow this car I did ask the studio
to paint a target on the wall in front
of his partner hopes that he would help
him wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]